6 23 here on a Monday morning it is
National mental health day really it's a
worldwide issue here we're bringing
mindfulness back to the workplace we're
talking about it certainly joining this
morning by Leticia escamilla with mind
fuel in motion which brings meditation
and mindfulness
like this to the workplace to work can
you hear that I don't know if you can
hear it I hear it yes uh through
workshops we're trying to find
mindfulness at work and mental Fitness
is sort of the key of what you're trying
to do for folks so what is mental
Fitness so mental Fitness really is
about nourishing and strengthening the
mind so really quickly we know physical
fitness right yoga as we were talking
about going to a gym things like that we
know what that looks like we know what
it feels like but we need to do the
exact same thing for our mind and we
can't actually see it right the way we
can see the results and feel when we're
doing physical fitness but it's the same
thing we need to strengthen the minds to
work for us not against us well and
especially you know we the pandemic was
such a burden on all of us and I think a
lot of us are still getting through that
but you know we're back at work and how
do you find mindfulness when you've got
tasks to do it's a nine to five job
maybe you're working in the casino floor
maybe you're a waiter waitress or
something how do you find mindfulness
when you have those tasks to do yeah
great question so I have three tips if
you don't mind sharing and going through
them really quick so the first one one
really is taking your breaks and getting
away from the devices getting away from
anything that distracts you from
yourself and I really want to say
especially like take your lunch break
like go and take your lunch break away
from a device away from your phone and
actually enjoy your food nourish your
body with that food drinking water
things like that and really just
disconnect for a little bit during that
time and not try to think about work or
do those tasks because they're waiting
for you right after but it's hard to get
that in mind right it's hard to think
about that what what are some of the
detriments to only focusing on work and
not finding time to be mindful yeah well
that's where worry and stress comes
along that's what burnout comes along
you know resentment yes all of those
things are kind of like what comes if we
think like we have to keep going with
that hustle and bustle that we've kind
of been told it's okay to slow down a
little bit because that way we can
actually be more productive in the
workplace and in our life in general
you're refueling you said you're
refueling your mind yes so important so
through your what you do you try and
teach people to be mindful at work and
have this mental Fitness what is what's
something we can do right here to find
some some awareness now here at 6 25 in
the morning for folks getting ready at
home yeah so if you're getting ready
right now John you're going to do a
little bit I am already ready so we're
okay you're ready but if you want to
pause for a second in this moment I
invite you to quickly Just Close Your
Eyes sit down find a comfortable seat
which John is doing so beautifully
showing as an example and just close
your eyes and this is called ladder
breathing we're going to do it really
quickly okay so you're just going to
inhale three counts so one two three we
hold at the top for three two one and
gently release for three two one and
that's just an example we can do that
three times you know before your day
throughout the day especially when
you're feeling you know the the
challenge or you're feeling overwhelmed
take a moment and just connect back with
yourself remind yourself of your why why
do you show up in life in general and
then go back and do your tasks and go
back to work and
take breaks and then also movement is
the final one movement's so important I
know that a lot of times at work you
know that can be challenging to go
outside and take a walk but even at our
desk you know I'm not gonna lie I sneak
in bathrooms you know and do things just
to have that moment to myself and
stretch and move and you know remind our
body to you know it's not good for our
body to be stagnant especially when
we're at the computer hunched over on
our phones good stuff well Leticia
escamilla thank you very much for
joining us be mindful when you're
heading out the door this morning find
time take your break